We're really fortunate to have our language abilities. Because of language,
humans are able to think and discuss abstract ideas. This is different from
other animals who communicate with each other. But they can only do so by
signaling other members of their species about immediate situations, such as
being hungry, hurt, or ready to reproduce. Such as using mating dances or
mating songs from birds. As we saw in lesson three, humans have evolved and our
brains grown larger, and as a result, we've been able to develop language. Our
ancestors, homo neanderthalensis, had a very primitive language, which we call
a protolanguage. So protolanguage is a rudimentary language, also known as
pre-language, and it was used by earlier species of homo. Now as we evolved our
brain size increased. So did our ability to develop and use language. Both
psychologists and anthropologists have suggested, that the complexity of the
brain and our ability to use language coevolved, which makes sense. With this
increase in brain size We would be able to think and communicate more complex
and abstract ideas. Furthermore, as the size of social groups increased, so did
our need to be able to communicate effectively with others. Our ability to
communicate allowed us to form communities. To hunt together, protect each
other, and even develop the ability to cultivate land.